bella spiega sempre venuto questo nuovo
video sono fa vj ci siamo sull'ultimo
episodio per mia gioia soprattutto di
offerte del gioco per loculo street che
questo caso brutto livelli in finire sta
cosa che è durata fin troppo già non ce
la posso più fare sto cazzo di cavo a
tra poco
ok ragazzi ci siamo siamo sull'ultimo li
devo fare l'ultimo livello che non mi
ricordo quale tra l'altro c'è anche
aphex due hanno fatto due amica che gli
saggiati comunque ragazzi faccio
l'ultimo prima che muoia re la cosa è
molto probabile come cazzo si clicca qui
capraia per me è perfetto alla prossima
ragazzi perfetto allora uomini che bello
sempre musica da sala d'aspetto grazie
bellissimo comunque ragazza potesse
cagata qui veramente di carnival è
l'ultima che mi manca poi ho finito a
quella reale manor perché poi ogni piano
è bellissimo c'è un edificio della
madonna in sede fronte lega io ho già i
lecca lecca possiamo aprire queste porte
che so ma che bello ma sull no ma qui si
paga il biglietto no perché troppo
stingo funziona la torcia che non si
vede un cazzo tipo ma cos'è sta roba
congregazione tra l'altro c'è un cielo
oggi pieno di stelle fanta cos'è this
way circus annonari qua perfetto dopo
giorno sentite che a torce perfetto hot
dogs mi piaccio fame da dami non dogg
zio grazie già mi sta piacendo questo
comunque fantastico wall of the week
cazzo ma raiola giuro sono veramente
contento di riuscire a fare sti giochi
no perché mi mettono una allegria che fa
paura che è andato a fuoco per ragazzi e
sentito dei rumori bruttissimi non so da
dove prova a fuoco qualcosa quindi ok
qualcosa dello togo è fatto avendo io
dog ragazzi non avrai cinque tappe che
shop i due avevano seriamente perché
cazzo sta andando a fuoco tutto ragazzi
non voglio saperlo ragazzi andiamo
avanti che è meglio comunque madonna che
che chi allegria in sto posto veramente
una cosa incredibile
io sto andando avanti a cazzo non so
neanche dove si salve c'è per caso un
clown brutto che vuole farmi uno
scherzetto devo buttare la spazzatura di
temi vuole insomma c'è una porta fanta
chi è caccia e sulle luci nel va bene
macchinetta no io le voglio le patatine
prendi la patatina fiction calcerà che
non funziona è permesso entrare in
questo caso è sempre va beh no veramente
amia è stato l'unico questi faccia
mentre il dog per te lui dopo va bene le
patatine me ne prendo ragazzi ma quanti
cassinis tributo diciamo questi sì mi fa
un panino
non voglio più il panino va bene così ci
ho ripensato ragazzi fino a dio cioè io
ho chiesto solo un panino era andava
bene dire di no ma va bene anche così ma
se non sicure se giostra cioè mi danno
una spoon senso di sicurezza incredibile
ci andiamo
ma perché ho dei brutti ricordi delle
giostre anche con lacustri quella bibbia
di pagliaccio dov'è andato a finire che
per gli sbatte le porte in faccia se ne
vanno
le avete impilati bene sti barili lascia
ampia io continuo a seguire i cartelli
che l'elettricità a minchia propri cioè
sprechiamola tranquillamente così natale
è passato e non è che dovete accendere
tutte le luci è l'ambientazione più
horror che abbia mai visto in tutta la
mia vita che ascolta zio c'è una un
cavallo lavoro visto che non cavano
seriamente perché c'è una giostra che ci
perché c'è un cavallo o ma che bello
cavallino vieni qua tesoro fini è bello
josè mari dando a ok fido destriero ti
va di di farmi cavalcare sulla tua
bellissima sella no guarda ci ha
ripensato el'appetito ovunque bon
appétit in che la barca va
scalda zio ma se vedendo un fisco amico
che cazzo è bella la giostra comunque
non riuscirò mai ad avere degli hot dog
in questo gioco c'è un'altra porta se mi
sbatte in faccia anche questa vi ammazzo
la mamma ve lo dico permesso boss hog
grazie ok no perché l'ho vista veramente
brutta
oddio mica mi viene da vomitare
tantissime quando lei per forza nel buio
io tornerò indietro quasi sta roba qua e
reader nella novità non provatelo anche
voi assurdo usciamo lingua che è meglio
preferisco prendermi spaventi che
vomitare sinceramente anche ci manca
vuoi anche le montagne russe se hai
voglia già tanto mattia solo quel è un
labirinto cos'è sta roba
l'unico più noi o no ragazzi questo
epico luglio è va beh ti spalmo gli hot
dog in faccia c'è un pupazzo maniaco che
dall'inizio continua a dar da salvino
ditemi se è normale che cos'è no merda
il cavallo no che bello chiaro perché è
morto così è stato quel pagliaccio di
meglio non so già che è stato il
pagliaccio colpa sua o andremo a dunque
non si fanno queste cose i cavalli c'è
mio dio un altro cava ma chi cazzo di
cavalli ci sono il suo posto ragazze
della st musica comunque porca [ __ ]
mi sono pagato in mano bellissimo
veramente è finito questa purga perfetto
mi fate tornare a casa per cortesia
graziano veramente non ne posso più
bello complimenti perfetto ragazzi è
stato meraviglioso
volete una fa a fette 2 ho fatto tutti e
tre tutti i livelli
masochismo a livelli incredibili farò di
sicuro anche affetto e due perché è
veramente bello giocare queste cose
seriamente
ma sono i cassoni titoli di coda
bellissimo da adesso li metto anch'io
nel mio assenso rischio fa vj vantano
abbia nei titoli di coda benissimo
la caccia nella cazzo di dubstep che
meglio comunque ragazzi è stato
meraviglioso giocare ad affetto spero
che vi sia piaciuto io chiudo qua perché
questa musica mi sta tartassando i
maroni abbastanza quindi ragazzi
concluso b l'episodio consento servito è
piaciuto ha lasciato commento mi piace
anche a faccia di facebook e come noi
video tratta descrizione forse dovresti
di sì ha proseguito bella ragazzi